مر مر انا معي بعض السجانين اللي بتحس ان
هو من داخله انسان طبعا الاغلبيه
بكون مجرد من انسانيته خالص ويكون يعني
تخرج من مدرسه الوحشيه مدرسه النظام
الاسدي يعني نسميها مدرسه صناعه الوحشيه
بيكون صنعوا منه وحش كامل بكون مجرد من كل
ما هو انسان يدخله ايه لكن بعض السجانين
بقاوموا او بيكون عندهم حصانه ذاتيه
لاسباب ما لاي سبب كان يعني
يضل محتفظ بجزء من انسانيته او كل
انسانيته ولكن هو مغلوب على امره هو موظف
بده يؤدي العمل
او اجباري والا يعني بده يعني يعاقب
كثير من الاشخاص اللي كانوا يجوا يبداوا
كمجندين او كعسكارنا بيكونوا يعني لينين
في البدايه بيكونوا بعد يعني ما صلب عودهم
تماما بالتعذيب وبالقمع والى ما هنالك ومن
ثم يعتادون على الامر لدرجه ان الموضوع
عندهم طبيعي طبعا هذا اللي انا عم بقصد
فيه هو صناعه الوحشيه يعني تحول الانسان
الى وحش وبالتدريج من خلال التدريب ومن
خلال الاعتياد
ان تزجه بهذا الموقع بالدربوا على ان يكون
وحش بتخليه يتعود على ان يكون وحش